[Music]
i never thought in a million years that
i would be here in japan singing the
music that my grandmother introduced me
to
i'm a testament to say that no matter
how big your dreams are they can
definitely be achieved
[Music]
[Music]
is a form of japanese music so it's only
sung in japan it is considered an older
genre of music
i call it japanese blues because all of
the lyrics are very sad melodramatic
they often talk about lost loves and
heartbreak
it uses a lot of imagination it really
doesn't spell out the meaning of the
song for you so everyone who listens to
the music can have their own
interpretation
i was born and raised in pittsburgh
pennsylvania my grandmother she was
originally from yokohama i basically
went to my grandmother's house just
about every weekend
she listened to bangkok music all the
time i think it was a way for her to
keep japan in her heart even while she
was living in the u.s
i started singing around five years old
my grandmother would always say you sing
so well just to see a smile on her face
would just brighten my day because i
loved her so much
because i had so much love for anka and
wanted to know what the lyrics i was
singing meant i started studying
japanese in high school and throughout
college
i was always interested in japan and
where my mom and my grandmother came
from so i moved to japan to become an
inca singer
[Music]
the very first time i stood on the stage
and sang for a crowd was actually on tv
kind of like american idol i was given
so much praise and it made me feel
really really good
they were just so surprised like why
would a 20-something american be
listening to a genre like this and it
kind of worked in my favor
[Music]
i started singing professionally in
2008. there's never been
an american who's been on stage singing
anka professionally here in japan i've
had the opportunity to do different
types of songs children's songs musicals
tv dramas
i think i've been really embraced
wholeheartedly from the japanese
audience me singing
really was a way for me to connect to
japan and connect with my grandmother
and to this day the love i have for anka
has not changed
[Applause]
[Music]
you